hello everyone we'll be starting in more
10 minutes thank you for joining
and meanwhile we begin with today's
session maybe you can introduce yourself
in the chat box and tell us about your
educational background and research and
trust
foreign
hello everybody good morning can anybody
can everybody hear me
yeah we can hear you
all right so we will start
uh today's webinar
and good morning everyone my name is
jabs
and welcome to this session i want to
start by introducing our company vision
and team that stands behind the various
resources and training programs that we
will go over today
omixlogic is a program for
bioinformatics training that was
developed in collaboration between pine
biotech
and topper bioinformatics research
center at the university of
let haifa just minimize this on the side
and the company was started as a result
of technology transfer from the center
which was founded by dr alfred tauber
and dr lynette barotsky
dr alfred tauber comes from a medical
background has extensive
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of inflammation and has
been recognized internationally for his
generous support of many research
projects and initiatives that support
data science training and applications
in medicine
dr leonid brodsky is a director of the
tower bioinformatics research center at
the university of haifa and is an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics and over
the course of his career has developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team includes experts in
bioinformatics computer science and
training
some of our team members will be
presenting uh today as well
omixlogic bioinformatics
yeah i'm sorry to interrupt we actually
i think you didn't let's play on the
presentation so we can see your view of
this lines
um let me see
sorry for that technical
can you see my screen
yeah press the play button
is that better
uh we can still see the the same thing
so
do you have another screen or something
no i don't
can you maybe just quickly close it and
put it back on because we can still see
or just close the side you see the side
the edit screen just so that we can see
the main screen
that's fine
can you see my
screen now
no it's same thing but it's okay let's
just keep going just go through the
slides manually
okay
so um omixlogic bioinformatics training
offers professional certification based
on award-winning curriculum and support
of research project
and we have served over 20 000 students
around the world and former
relationships with the universities and
networks that can now offer easy access
to such trainings in the us
india africa and south america
the goal of amix logic programs is to
provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and peer example developing a
growing community with shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life and data sciences
we do this by leading each participant
through a well-defined learning process
in order to create a clear path of skill
development omixlogic employs the
bloom's taxonomy levels of learning
this approach starts with the basics
recalling facts and understanding the
terminology
ability to remember the material
with this space the learning builds to
conceptual knowledge being able to
understand concepts and apply
information to new situations
then the goal is to be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods
this leads to the highest level of
learning the ability to design and
create original work
in the program we will utilize technical
aspects of the omics logic portal
designed to make this process flexible
students can learn anywhere and at any
time their progress is quantified and
activity is tracked using a specifically
designed point system
after acquiring basic skills quizzes
offer an opportunity to check
comprehension the central focus of this
activity
is a profile where users acquire levels
and badges
each module will have lessons and
assignments that come with an
independent certificate of completion
next our team will demonstrate the
various options so that you are familiar
with the process and can make most of
the program
now i'll pass the next presentation to
sonalika
thank you so much
for the introduction of the company and
the team
now i would like to take you all through
the program page and also discuss some
of the important things that you almost
know
uh by being a part of this particular
program
so uh the very first thing that is
important to get started is to have an
account on the omix object learn portal
that's absolutely free so the link is in
the chat box if you have not signed up
yet please uh sign up you can sign up
now as well and if you feel any
technical issue then we can assist you
uh
the very next thing once you sign up is
that you update your profile so to get
started just click on your email id
that's up here in the uh top menu bar
that will redirect you to your profile
tab please make sure that you have an
updated profile with the profile picture
put your name in the title case because
you will get an automated certificate
once you complete a particular course
work uh under the program
please make sure that you have uh all
your social media accounts connected so
that we can feature your profile on your
progress and also have an updated bio
that will include about an educational
background and also your research
interests so that our mentors and the
community knows about your interests and
background
the very first thing to get started is
to make sure that you have the starter
subscription active as a part of the
program
because this starter subscription is
going to give you the access to all the
start lessons on the omixological vocal
as a part of
the program and also please make sure
that you have the badge middle genomics
in your profile that will give you the
access to the program page
now i quickly take you all to the
program page and show you what this
program page includes and why is it
important to keep a track on this
program page
so this is the page for meta genomic
data analysis the summer program that we
are starting with today thank you so
much for just sharing the link in the
chat please follow this program page on
this page you will find the links to the
whole session schedule now here you you
can see that you have the calendar on
which all dates we have all these
sessions reviewed and also you have the
topics that we'll be covering along with
each and every topic you have a list of
associated online resources
now these associated online resources
are actually the lessons on the
omixlogic learn portal that you are
required to follow as a part of each and
every session
now after the session is complete you
can see the recording of the session
here on the program page itself it's
important for you to go through the
recording once again to revisit the
topics that we discuss and also complete
each and every lesson
as a part of the program
once you complete or go to the recording
and also complete the associated
resources you'll find a complete session
icon on the
program page under each and every
session you need to click on the
complete session icon and do so for each
and every session to complete the
program
and once you scroll down on the program
page itself you will find a list of
resources that you are supposed to
complete so you need to go through
introduction to bioinformatics bytes and
molecules metagenomics and also the
example project of metagenomics we'll
discuss more about all of these
resources in the session today to get
you all started
and last but not the least we are going
to stay connected via our skype group so
i'm going to share the link to our skype
group with all our participants with all
our program participants and you'll stay
connected with the mentors
in that group so what whichever
questions you have please post them in
the group so that the mentors can assist
you
that was it on my end and now i'm going
to pass on the stage to mr ilya brodsky
to get started with today's session over
to eureka
thank you so much
and jax for this introduction let me
share my screen
hello everyone and welcome to this first
session of our meta genomics training
program so what we'll do today is i'll
talk briefly about some of the basic
things that you have to know about
metagenomics for some of you this will
be a review for some of you many things
might be new but i'll also point you to
some resources on our portal
where you can find important information
uh either on the basic uh terms that we
will use throughout the program
as well as some practical exercises that
you can get started with
so
like i said i will talk a little bit
about some of the terminology some of
the methods that are used to generate
the data and i'll also talk a little bit
about the types of projects that we will
review or case studies where you can
really see how meta genomics is used now
together with myself uh dr raghavendran
lakshmi narayan is going to be mentoring
the program and in the next session he
will talk to you more about the
technical details
uh but also this is a program
that
is designed for you to succeed and so
we're hoping that you will update your
profile let us know about your
background your research interests or
your industry interest and really allow
us to connect with you
our team will reach out to you if you
have any questions and we have a support
group on skype or on slack where we can
interact and address any questions that
you might have
so the purpose of today's session is to
discuss
the microbiome how we can use
metagenomic sequence analysis to study
the microbiome
and understand how microorganisms
interact in their natural environment
looking at the community composition and
structure
thinking about species richness and
understanding the functional roles that
some of these microbial communities can
play in many areas related to human
health and disease as well as
biotechnology and agriculture so the
program is really designed to introduce
different types of case studies that
illustrate the way the field of
metagenomics has been evolving what are
some of the practical tools and skills
that you have to have to be able to
analyze this data independently and also
what are some practical tips tutorials
and maybe skills that you should have to
be able to integrate this
quantity of information from different
databases from the reads in the fast q
files and also the different metadata
that you have about your samples to
produce
plots that help you interpret the data
biologically so you'll be able to
by the end of this program process a
data set
understand the composition ask questions
about the microbiome and review
literature that will help you find
answers and make biological sense of the
data that you have analyzed
the way the program is organized is it's
really divided up into several different
stage
stages
the first one is logic
then we will talk about practice and
then we will
kind of transition into a project stage
so why is logic
important
logic is important because we need to
understand
what kind of data are we going to be
dealing with
and what kinds of questions could
potentially be asked of this data
now different types of data represent
different types of biological
phenomena and so we
can generate data that describe this
biological phenomena but depending on
what kind of data we have about maybe
the phenomena maybe the number of
samples
or the way that we uh plan to process
and analyze the data will determine what
kinds of questions we can ask
so moving a little bit more into the
practical domain we will talk about
different types of analytical approaches
now the analytical approaches can be
divided into two types
the first one is processing or really
preparing the data for analysis
and then the second one is more on how
to work with the process data and make
sense of it and that can include
several different things so one of them
is kind of a standard process which we
call a pipeline where we take the input
files we go through several different
steps and we get some predefined output
in many cases
that kind of an output requires further
investigation and that is driven both by
statistical analysis visualization
machine learning and sometimes it's
driven by a biological intuition
and so that's where
we cannot cover everything that
potentially could be done but this will
be more based on a case study so in each
case we will see what kinds of questions
are being asked what methods are being
used to process the data how is that
data then analyzed
and annotated and then what kinds of
interpretation or conclusions we can
arrive
helping
to study and find relationships between
phenotype and what we find in this
microbiome or metagenomic data
so this will be covered in several
different sessions
some of the sessions will be live like
today
some of them will be pre-recorded
today's session is live you can ask us
questions you can comment if you have
any specific things that you expect from
this program we would love to know but
in many cases we want to give you the
flexibility of going through the topics
that we have planned and so that is why
all of the sessions will be recorded but
also sometimes you will have access to a
structured material
on our omixlogic portal which will
include
text images video quizzes exercises with
coding or running pipelines
and that's why it's important to get
familiar already
with the portal how it works and how the
different contents present on that
portal can be leveraged and there you
will find
some basic coursework
as well as practical exercises in r and
python i will primarily talk about r
because it's extensively used in
metagenomic data analysis and also
because it is providing us with very
nice looking figures that we can
directly use in research publications
but the online portal really covers the
basics some practical and uh gives you
some case studies that are structured
around publications where experts have
been analyzing the data and coming to
those conclusions so it's a good way to
understand not only how to technically
approach a subject but how have experts
designed uh sequence the data and made
the interpretation of the results
together with the portal we will be
using the t-bioinfo platform
so the tbi info platform is a point and
click interface that allows you to
analyze big data without having to
download the data to your computer
without having to learn how to write
code in bash
and really connect multiple complex
analysis methods into a process a
pipeline where you can get results that
are interpretable in a quicker way
so to demonstrate how this is used in
the context of metagenomics i will show
you a brief example and then we will
talk about how
that can be used either to study
metagenomics or to understand the
relationship between phenotype and the
specific types of data that we will be
working with
so let me transition from my slides to
the actual portal now if you have
already signed up on the onyx logic
portal and you have access now to
the program
your account information should be a
also
should allow you to log in to this
portal to this platform called the t by
info platform
so pause here thank you jessica for
sharing the link
please let me know
those that are participating and want to
follow along if you were able to
get into this link and also if you hover
over this profile if you can see your
email address here on top so you know
that you're logged in
and maybe you can share that in the chat
yes no
maybe something like that so i will give
you just a couple of minutes and then we
will go on from there
okay if you still have not created an
account
then i recommend going first to the
learn portal
and on the learn portal you can easily
create a free account
unfortunately if you're just creating
your account today you won't have access
to the portal to the platform right away
it will take a little bit of time for
you to receive those credentials so if
you don't have the credentials you can
just observe but for the next session i
highly recommend to try and log in and
if you're not able to log in or you have
some issues with logging in please
support our or please reach out to our
support team
at support pine.com
all right so let's move on
and here you will see a
section a table called areas of analysis
you will see here many different types
of analysis included transcriptomic data
genomic data epigenomic data etc and
right here at the bottom we have a
dedicated section for metadata genomic
data analysis
so metagenomic data
comes in several different formats and
that's why we have them divided into
several different sections
we'll talk about some of them and we'll
use some of them quite extensively to
analyze data you will find that
the selection of methods
is driven in many cases by the type of
data that you have and so we'll talk a
little bit about the types of
metagenomic data in just a few minutes
but today i will show you a brief
example
of a specific type of data called
amplicon
16s ribosomal rna gene
where we amplify the 16s ribosomal rna
gene to understand the composition of a
sample
and so this
link right here will give us access to a
demo
in the demo we can build a pipeline
without having to upload data and right
away get results so we don't have to
wait for the processing time either
so if you do have access you can click
on there and you can follow along with
me if you don't you can just observe and
again you will have an exercise for next
time where you can follow along
now every time that you click on a
button you get a description that
explains what are we going to do
and how and so in this case we're going
to be using the data 2 pipeline data 2
pipeline was developed specifically
because this kind of data
is noisy it has a lot of issues a lot of
issues that can make finding signal
difficult
and so because it is made to denoise the
data
we have to go through a whole series of
steps to first clean up the reads and
prepare them for the downstream analysis
and so that's what we're going to do
first we're going to check our quality
of the reads then we're going to select
only reads that are paired
after that we're going to merge those
pairs together
then we will assign
operational taxonomic units to those
merged pairs of reads and remove chimera
creates reads that came from several
different locations so they kind of
create this hybrid that cannot be
annotated
once we do this we have to use a
database a reference that helps us
assign each one of those sequences
to a taxonomic level
and the taxonomic level basically has a
database of sequences and the closest
sequence helps us align
the otus with the taxonomy
after we have that information we want
to understand what types of sequences do
we have and to do that we have to create
a phylogenetic tree the phylogenetic
tree in this case
can be created using this a package in r
which stands for analysis of
phylogenetics and evolution
once we have that phylogenetic tree we
can then start inter
kind of analyzing and integrating all of
that information to perform statistical
analysis and study the composition of
our sample and that can be done with a
package called filoseek again we will go
through these packages during our
sessions and we we can use them in r or
we can use them on the platform but what
they do is they
integrate the statistical analysis with
plotting and we will see how this
plotting helps us understand
what kind of data we have
and uh to the question in the chat yes
this video is going to be available uh
for everyone to see
but especially important for those that
are participating in the full program
and then we're just going to produce
some visual interactive visualization on
the platform that will allow us to study
the data set that we have
okay so for those of you
that followed along your pipeline
connects all of these dots together and
what you have in the end are output
files that you can download
and they typically are produced from
every step that we selected there will
be something
from those steps but also we have here
several plots that we can view
interactively
so the first important plot is the tax
to proportionate abundance bar plot and
again you will have a whole session
dedicated to
how this plot is produced and what
exactly does it represent but here
briefly i would like to point your
attention to several important things
first of all
when we talk about metagenomic data that
represents the microbiome we're studying
a whole community together and because
we have different levels
of
depth for the different samples that we
have samples here are on the x-axis we
are expecting a lot of variation and so
we want to
perform normalization by looking at
proportionate abundance and not direct
abundance from these samples
so once we have them we can now see that
specific taxa
again here we have the full taxonomic
classification written out but as you
remember bacteria is the kingdom right
so it's not going to change but then
after this you see that some of these
taxonomic levels are going to start to
change and so as we look at our
proportions here we can see this green
taxa which is bacterial deities
vary between our samples
and so the obvious question now
is okay what does that tell us about the
samples themselves right this is a lot
of detail how do we
kind of look at this detail from a high
level to understand what kinds of
differences do we have and to do that
and we're going to again go through this
in detail in one of our sessions we use
a statistical analysis called
non-metric dynamic
dimensionality scaling which is a plot
in 3d
that we can look at and we can see here
each one of these dots represents a
sample that we just saw so here we have
the samples on the x-axis and on the
y-axis proportional abundance here in
our nmds plot we have three dimensions
that are from the non-metric
dimensionality scaling and the dots
represent in the individual sample so
you can see that the samples are of two
types
chao which is a standard type of feed
used for mice and hfd which stands for
high fat diet
and so as we look around we can notice
two major things
the first one is that we have an outlier
and the second one is that actually if
we probably removed the outlier we would
be able to see some
pretty good separation between our
samples right if we find some kind of a
way to position this plot we could find
a line that could separate the dots so
of course that is dependent on removing
this outlier and that is really the
essence of this type of analysis that we
will go through in the full program
this analysis is going to be iterative
which means that you will start
somewhere
you will perform some standard tasks and
then you will start asking questions
what do i see and what does it mean and
if i understand what it means what are
some next steps that i should take to
make sure that i'm getting something
that i understand
makes sense but also is reproducible and
could tell me something about the
biology that i'm trying to study
so this is a very brief example again we
will go into much more detail throughout
the program but it illustrates the
essence of the type of bioinformatics
steps that you would have to go through
and understand to be able to work with
such microbiome data
and by the way if you have any questions
please feel free
to
ask those questions in the chat
so we talked a little bit about this
pipeline
we will talk about different methods of
statistical analysis and machine
learning and importantly we will try to
reproduce a lot of the plots and try to
understand the relationship between the
steps that we do the code that we write
and the outputs that we have
and so as we go throughout the whole
program you will be familiar with how
you use different types of packages
different types of methods of analysis
different types of visual plots that you
should be expecting and importantly how
to troubleshoot all of these steps
because in so many cases in
bioinformatics understanding where the
problem is
you
guides you to
kind of uncovering the issue with either
your code or your analysis approach or
your data
so let's briefly talk about
microorganisms and the microbial
community
now that we've seen
all of this information kind of from a
high level
what are we trying to study actually
um okay so the question is is the r code
used for each step of the pipeline shown
available
no
not all of the code that you just saw
was an r some of the code was
written in c some of it was
scripts and bash
some of it was in r and some of it was
in python so it's really a combination
of different types of codes that were
put together in a single workflow and
that workflow in the end produces these
outputs which are either files or
interactive outputs
but the focus of the program will
primarily be on how to use a lot of
those different standard steps as well
as some coding in r so the majority of
the coding that we'll do will be in r
hopefully that answers your question
so let's
briefly talk about microorganisms and
the microbial community
what are we trying to study
and how are we going to be able to study
this community right why is it new and
and why is it useful
so the connection between disease and
microorganisms has been established
already in the 1800s and already towards
the end of the 19th century laboratory
methods for growing microorganisms in a
lab culture were developed helping
characterize them with staining
these studies provided important
information about bacteria function in
isolation however it was soon apparent
that most microorganisms don't live as
individuals but live in complex
communities
and today we know that microorganisms as
they are called microbiota
can be very different in different
places because they form a stable
community
and so one of the efforts of the
community that studies the microbiome is
to try to characterize both what is
healthy
establish a baseline and how do we
measure deviation from that healthy
condition
so here you can see that the number of
studies has been exponentially
increasing from the time that these
methods were introduced and today we
have a pretty good sense of these
different established communities in the
human body for example
so here you can see some
typical members of the microbiota in the
mouth
skin and other parts of the body and
here you can see the number of studies
of published research papers on human
microbiota
now the majority of these studies focus
exclusively on the bacteria but the
microbiome actually includes bacteria
as well as others other members of the
community including the virum which as
you know bacteriophages are important
members of that bacterial community that
regulate the composition
can infect bacteria bacteria fights them
off so
they do form kind of they do influence
each other
as well as archaea
and
other members as well so when you think
of the microbiome it's really all of the
microorganisms
but when we
will study the types of analyses that we
will perform we'll focus on one of them
and typically it's going to be the
bacteria
now in different parts of the body there
are different
numbers of bacterial species and in many
cases you will find an association
between the environment that they live
in
and the community that they form for
example
acidity levels
access to oxygen and things like that
are important factors that actually
determine
how this community evolves and is one of
the reasons
why we cannot just isolate a lot of
these individuals
to study them in a lab because we would
have to recreate the exact conditions
where they grow and those conditions are
in part dependent on the composition of
the microbiome so it's very difficult to
extract the microbiome and actually
reproduce it in a lab even though some
attempts are being
made
so
uh typically when we think of the
microbiome we think of the gut and the
the digestion part of how the microbiome
functions but many other communities are
also as important for example
we can talk about the skin right so on
the skin surprisingly even though we
wash our skin all the time we apply
different things to our skin
these bacteria form a very stable
community and the reason is because
of course there are pores and the
bacteria populate the pores as well as
live
in different cracks between the skin
cells and so as a result
we can see that bacteria fungi and
viruses form a stable community that
starts interacting with the epithelium
in our skin and that is why some of
these
studies focused on the skin microbiome
are importantly uh
importantly
are very important for understanding
of how to treat diseases and how
potentially these bacterial communities
could be interrupted so to study a lot
of this many different international
projects have been started and those
include the nih human microbiome project
uh the british gut project the american
gut projects the different kinds of gut
projects micro rosetta initiative
there's even a project for studying the
microbiome in space
through the nasa
consortium called gene lab
as well as different types of clinical
studies involving the microbiome like
the gut microbiome sub study for cancer
prevention or alzheimer's gut microbiome
project or the nurses health study
so a lot of interesting data sets have
been reposited on in the public domain
as a result of these consortia
and we will go through some of these
examples in this program using them as
case studies to really understand what
kinds of questions are people asking and
what kinds of information can we obtain
for example about the individuals that
are being studied the microbiome effects
on human health as well as many other
applications of the microbiome
so
let's go now and talk a little bit more
about where this data comes from so we
talked about the microbiome we talked
about where we want to get to how is
this data generated
so the way this data is generated
is using what's called metagenomic
sequencing and so to understand the
process we'll kind of go through the
history of metagenomic sequences and
exactly what is being sequenced
and then that will explain a lot of the
things in the metagenomic sequence
analysis and our ability to annotate and
interpret the results that we just saw
so we'll talk a lot here about what's
called 16s amplicon sequencing and it's
a technique that was developed because
the 16s
ribosomal rna gene
is an established gene that has a common
function across many different types of
bacterial species
and
the variation has specific
indications for the levels of taxonomy
so the 16s ribosomal rna sequencing is
also low cost flexible and it provides
us a long enough read
that can actually answer a lot of the
questions that we have about the
microbond composition
why is that
the reason is because here you can see
the 16s ribosomal rna gene so it folds
into the structure and has what are
called different regions so these v1 to
v9 are the different regions
and
the full gene is approximately 1500 base
pairs long
but it also has specific conserved
regions these regions that we see poking
out are conserved and those are between
30 and 100 base pairs long
now in between you have
variable regions
and then you have conserved regions and
so the
databases that we will use to annotate
where these reads came from
actually contain those sequences already
annotated by the strains of bacteria
that they come from
one of those uh databases is called the
silva database we'll use that
extensively but also there are others
like green genes rdp and the ncbi
national center for biotechnology
information also contains
that as well now there have been
publications that have compared how this
is
how these databases
annotate the different taxa using the
16s ribosomal rna gene sequence and it
comes out that two major things are
important number one
uh when everything is driven by users
there's a lot of noise because maybe
there are some uh you know opposite
views of which taxes that came from but
also because someone needs to validate
and clean up and constantly kind of
interact with the data to make sure it's
up to date and it turns out that silva
is one of those repositories that is
most actively supported reviewed and
validated and so that's why in a lot of
cases we'll see people use the silva
database to annotate their metagenomic
data
now how is this taxonomic classification
actually performed so we have here the
ribosomal rna so the ribosome consists
of two parts the larger part and the
smaller and they are called the subunits
so we have the 30s ribosomal subunit and
the gene that encodes for that subunit
is the 16s ribosomal rna gene
that gene
could be amplified and to amplify so we
extract the dna from the microbiome from
the actual biological sample
and then we need to amplify some target
region because we cannot sequence the
full 1500
base pair long
sequence
not with the luminous sequencers at
least but other sequencers could do that
but with a luminous sequencer sequencing
which is the most reliable
and cost effective in this case
you can see that the primer sequence has
to be designed for specific target
regions
now different combinations of these
hypervariable regions are used for the
actual sequencing sometimes it's just v3
sometimes just v4 sometimes v3 and v4
together sometimes you can add another
one of these hypervariable regions it
really depends on the level of taxonomy
that you would like to use
and the ability to amplify and then
sequence those reads
what essentially happens is that with
this amplicon approach if the less you
amplify the less of your data is going
to be used so the less information will
you be able to expect from your data
a comparison between the full 16s
ribosome rna gene for example sequenced
with nanopore or with pac bio compared
to illumina which would only use one of
the hyper variable regions is that you
lose about 50 percent of your data so
you get 50 percent more information if
you sequence the full gene
obviously variation in combinations of
the hypervariable regions also play a
role
but what you can do as a result
is uh actually look at the different
levels right so the more hyper variable
regions you have the deeper you can go
in the taxonomy so instead of just
looking at the species which obviously
bacteria is just one
or sorry kingdom instead of going
through the kingdom bacteria is just the
kingdom
you can go all the way to the species if
you sequence everything
if you only sequence some for example
two maybe you can only go to order or
family level and not any deeper
but essentially then you can look at the
body for example and
analyze the composition right so
proportions of different types of
taxonomies
and compare them between individuals
between groups of individuals or find
associations between individuals or
microbiota and some phenotype
so this will be the data preparation the
biological data preparation and this
would be the analysis now this is just
based on the sequence data what other
types of data can be used
for understanding not only what the
composition is but also importantly we
want to understand the function
so for sequencing dna based approaches
like 16s ribosomal rna or its gene
sequencing could be used its just
another gene that is used for
assigning taxonomy
but also we can use meta transcriptomics
or full metagenomics so full
metagenomics right here
means that we're trying to not only
select a gene for taxonomy but we would
like to then assemble everything that we
sequence into full genomes
that's a challenge because we don't know
all of the genomes so there is not a
comprehensive database to say these are
all the possible genomes let's just find
those
we're always expecting to find new
genomes and because they live in a
community we expect to be some drift
you know genetic drift a recombination
and other types of interactions that we
really cannot predict and so that makes
whole genome metagenomics challenging
another approach is to try to understand
well what genes are being expressed
again here the problem is we don't know
all the genes that could be present so
how do we measure their abundance right
how do we denoise this data and so that
is why the majority of the studies are
still relying on 16s ribosomal rna
however more and more whole genome
metagenomics is being performed and even
some meta transcriptomics is being done
today as well
in addition to that we can study the
proteins and metabolites that are being
produced
and that gives us another important
insight into not only what is being
done in the community but how is that
community interacting with the host
and to do that
ultimately
we would like to integrate all of this
information together and that brings us
to systems medicine approach or systems
biology approach to be able to
understand how all of this information
between the types of bacteria the types
of viruses the types of hosts that they
are in and the different impacts of
variables like diet drugs and other
things can play a role in this complex
system
so we won't go all the way into that
portion of it of how to integrate all
that data but we will definitely give
you a good sense of how you can get
started with metagenomics and then
hopefully that will give you enough
tools to continue and study other
methods as well that we will also
potentially cover in other programs
so let's talk now about some practical
examples and case studies that we're
going to review in this program
one interesting repository is the
american gut sample so this is a project
that was started first of all as a
research study but then was crowdfunded
and really offered to anyone who would
like to participate to be able to
understand several different things
first of all i would like to understand
about my own gut sample what is in it
what are the what are the proportions
and and what is the taxonomy
and maybe something is known about these
specific strains or speciesism in my
body
another important insight is that i
could compare my microbiome compared to
other microbiomes of other individuals
and since i know something about those
individuals for example what kinds of
diets they have or what kinds of
activity they
do throughout the week i could then
understand maybe where i stand in terms
of the comparison so here this large dot
represents this individual and the
little dots represent some of the other
members of this project and hear the
same way
so here
this project
the data is accessible online so what
we'll do is we'll actually take some of
the metadata and here you can see just a
sample comparison that we will do where
we will take individuals that exercise
rarely exercise regularly and we will
try to extract their data using the
sample id
and process this data to compare them to
each other we'll ask the question
does exercise in fact have any effect on
the microbiome composition
another example project that we'll talk
about is the skin microbiome how do we
study inflammation acne causes
inflammation of course skin rashes how
can we actually look at the different
types of inflammation caused by these
microbial communities and just find
associations right so again what's
important here is that we are dealing
with noisy data
a lot of the information that we need is
missing and when we ask these questions
we ask pretty general questions um and
and then if we want to go beyond the
general questions then we want to
actually functionally validate that what
we are saying
is true
a lot of times we cannot perform those
types of experiments on individuals so
what we'll do is we'll look at a mouse
study
that actually tries to isolate the
impact that the micro microbiome
composition plays
in the relationship between obesity
and anxiety
because really today when you look at
the literature that uh describes
microbial communities you will see that
a lot of that
is uh you know potentially very
impactful but the question is you know
is that really true right so there's a
lot of microbiome
you know theoretically could be involved
in almost anything but how do you know
that it's
microbiome and not anything else
so in this study
the authors actually designed an
experiment
where they took
mice just after their microbiome was
established
those mice were fed with different
samples with different diets
and
once those microbial communities were
established in the guts of these mice
they were
studied analyzed of course but then also
that microbiome was implanted into other
mice recipient mice
now the recipient mice did not have a
difference in diet but they got the
microbiome from different types of
donors
and because nothing else was different
between these mice and just the
implanted microbiome
they could test the difference in
their activity and in their response
sorry to different stimuli
and identify that in fact
only the microbiome had a contribution
to the levels of anxiety which is a very
interesting finding and a finding that
you will find being reproduced in other
studies as well
and so where does that leave us where
does that bring us to
well it actually helps us understand
many different things about the
microbiome first of all we know that
your healthy microbiome is established
in the early stages of your life
and that is primarily driven by the
maternal microbiome and your genetics
and environment and as
the infant about four years old that
microbiome is now established but is
continuing to be affected by the number
of micro uh antibiotics that are being
used as well as diet and exercise
and then throughout the stages of that
microbiome developing many different
scenarios could be explored and for many
of these we will look at examples and
case studies that really allow us to
study these things in detail and so one
of those we will look at microbial
colonization in infants
and how different bacteria get
established for example between vaginal
birth and
sea
section so different types of
births
as well as different types of use of
antibiotics we will also look at the
enterotypes right how these different
types of microbiota established in the
early infant stages are then affected by
different types of
lifestyles and environmental factors and
ultimately what are some of the general
kind of types of uh microbiota that we
expect and and they basically for the
adult microbiome
are typically separated into three
different enterotypes
that are based and highly associated
with both location and diet
and so because of all of these studies
today
as you probably all know you can measure
your microbial composition
at the preclinical stage right so
there's a lot of consumer
directed um
kind of
tests that you can take and you know
what is in your gut
the problem is that you know of course
there's a lot of noise and i think
there's a developing trust into how
these applications really work but it's
definitely an exciting area that a lot
of uh you know there's a lot of interest
at the pre-clinical stage what about the
clinical stage well in the clinical
stage we also are starting to see a lot
of innovative uses of the findings
coming from this type of research to
address very important types of
challenges that previously have not been
addressed using the microbiome for
example china approved an alzheimer's
treatment that targets the microbiome
or there are many studies that look at
the association between our ability to
metabolize different treatments and the
types of
responses to drugs
and even being able to develop a
microbial signature that will help us
predict for example in the case of
immunotherapy predict the
important toxic responses to
immunotherapy that some individuals have
so when we think about the microbiome
this also has a role to play in the
current pandemic and so a lot of people
are turning to studying the microbiome
to understand how does the micro biome
affect
uh the risk of being infected the length
of the disease and the speed of the
recovery
microbiome is not only used for human
health it is also extensively used in
other applications including
biotechnology and agriculture
and we will also look at some example
data sets that can help us understand
the way that the microbiome potentially
could be used as a fertilizer
because it plays a role of
kind of you know helping for example in
our body helping us
digest some of the food in the soil
helping the plant roots
extract the correct nutrients
from the ground and might be a very
effective
alternative to the types of
elements chemical
elements that are used to kind of
perform
the same function
so in conclusion
what is this program going to be about
this program is going to help us
understand different types of methods of
analysis that are used to analyze this
kind of data and develop an
understanding of the microbiome as we
saw in today's example we will go
through many different
types of analysis approaches and try to
understand the logic behind these
approaches and the types of outputs that
they produce
we will then look at some coding
exercises from very simple to more
advanced
and try to understand how to work with
this process structured data
extract the right kinds of information
and kind of look at it as a survey and
how do we analyze a survey we try to
look at the number of people that answer
certain questions in a certain way so we
will
take the similar approach to studying
the microbiome
what i want to leave you with today is a
little bit of further reading so before
you continue with the program
and before you start thinking about what
should i analyze in terms of microbiome
take a look at these three publications
so the first publication is going to be
based on this original project the human
microbiome project and we'll really tell
you about the different approaches
specifically bioinformatics approaches
that were designed to study the human
microbiome data
we will also
look at
the um different concept strategies and
advances in the microbiome i'm going to
share these links in just a second and
finally the website for the human
microbiome uh project itself where you
will see both the history
the current status and and future
directions for this important project so
let me just
quickly share
share those links with you
and i'll paste them in the chat
all right so
me
um
at this stage um i really want to open
uh the um
the stage for discussion
uh sorry because i might have pasted
this oh okay uh for discussion so if you
do have any questions uh please feel
free to ask
and um i'll give it just a couple more
minutes so if you have any questions you
can put them in the chat and i'll
address them one by one and uh in
addition to that i would like to pass
the stage back over to uh sonica to talk
a little bit more about uh making sure
that your profile is set up
uh that you know how to access the
different times that we will have our
sessions scheduled on and then once
those sessions are over how to access
the video material and how to interact
with our team using different channels
for
discussion you so much
for such a wonderful session and taking
uh all the participants to the resources
that we are going to take up in the
program
yes so as elia mentioned i would now
like to assist our program participants
with any of their technical issues if
there are any
so uh first of all please tell me if
you have signed up on the portal
please put a yes or one maybe in the
chat box to make sure that yes you have
signed up
i'll be awaiting the responses in the
chat
all right and those who have signed up
have you
updated your profile as well
so not an aparna you can sign up right
away and
if you face any technical issues then we
can help you out with that
certainly perfect
those who have not updated their
profiles they can update it as well
and just to make sure
yes or not i'll just give you the link
all right yeah
so i wanted to make sure one thing here
uh
you will be signing up on the portal and
create credentials for yourself so the
credentials that you create for yourself
on the portal you have to use the same
credentials every time you log in to the
portal
but for the t bio info server that is
the hands-on analysis uh server that
elia also showed for the very same
server i'm going to send you out the
credentials every program participants
every program participant is going to
have an educational license uh for one
month that is the duration of the
program so please make sure that you use
the very same credentials when you have
to sign up or login to the portal and
the server to um run your analysis
i'll repeat once again that you will be
creating the credentials for yourself
please use the synchro same credentials
to log into the portal or massage loan
portal and the credentials that i'll
send you over please use them to log in
to the diy info server
uh thank you for the hinting of that
question
and
now quickly i would like to take all the
interested participants who are present
here
through the program registration so
there were many uh many of you were
interested to just have a look at how
this program online training program is
going to work so i hope you all had a
good idea today about how we're going to
have these sessions conducted and how
you will be going through these
associated resources
run your pipelines and also go through
the quiz and do the analysis so now that
you are well aware of how this program
is going to work let me just take you
through the registration steps so that
you can register and get access to all
the resources that we discussed today
and also become the part of our upcoming
sessions
so here we have three different
subscription levels on the program page
itself those who have already enrolled
you are not going to see these three
subscription levels because yes you have
already picked it up the ones who were
interested to enroll on the program page
you will find three levels mentioned as
beginner intermediate and advanced in
the beginner level you will get the
access to such sessions that we have had
all the resources and all these three
different types of subscription levels
are going to remain the same which
includes such live sessions or recorded
sessions associated resources on the
omnislogic learn portal access to all
the course material on the omnilogic
learn portal and also an educational
license on the t bioinfo server to run
the analysis the difference lies in the
duration and also the access to
one-on-one mentorship guidance so in the
beginner level you will get the access
to mental guidance in such group
sessions as we have today
in the intermediate subscription level
you will get a chance to also schedule
one-on-one uh meeting with the mentor
that could be between you and your
mentor and discuss your questions your
doubts your ideas with the mentor and in
the advanced subscription level you'll
get some extra days to work on a
research proposal all right so in
addition to the duration of the program
you'll get some extra time period where
you work on your research proposal and
get started with your independent
research project as an outcome of the
training program so that is the main
difference between beginner intermediate
and advanced subscription level
i hope i was able to clearly specify the
difference if there is still any doubt
or question please put it in the chat
box so that we can clarify it
all right so if we have no more
questions at the moment
i
yes saranya you can definitely pick a
beginner level first and then upgrade it
to an advanced level
yes you can upgrade your level anytime
in the application
yes and the last thing that i wanted to
show all of you was this skype group
the participants who have joined the
program already i'm going to send you
the link to join our skype group please
make sure that you join this group uh
the mentors are also here in the group
and you can anytime put your question
when you're running a pipeline or if you
have any technical issue just to ensure
that your issue is answered on time
please make sure that you join the
channel
okay so elia on zyle is asking are there
any methods for combining or comparing
16s rdna and whole metagenome shotgun
dna analysis results
i think it has left it would be great if
he could answer your question on xyl so
i'm going to uh reply you back on your
question please put your mail id in the
chat for me
all right are there any more questions
if not then i think we are good to end
today's session before i do that i would
uh just drop in our mail ids in the chat
so
that you can reach out to us with any of
your queries later uh you can reach out
to us at marketing at
theatomixlogic.com for getting yourself
enrolled and miss pashthar will help you
get involved in the program
uh yes your subscription will be active
for the entire length of the program
that is one
month
and the starter subscription will give
you the access to all the start lessons
uh under the courses tab on the portal
yes definitely harsh all these options
have a certification
so there are two things here
you are going to complete some of the
courses as a part of this online
training program you will get individual
certificates for each and every course
that you complete that is point number
one and also you will get the
certificate for your program on
successful completion right so
let's say if i complete my complete
metagenomics course and also the project
example project that we discussed about
so i'll get certificates for both of
these and then when i complete the
program so i get a certificate for my
program as well this is how you can see
your certificate
uh yeah this is how you can see the
certificates for your courses and then
for your programs
this is a training program please don't
get confused between a program and the
courses courses are available on the
portal that you need to take up and the
programs are online winter kind of
training programs there are different
training programs that we hold every
month and this is one of them
and for the program you will have
another another certificate
uh yes on zyle we reach out to you thank
you for sharing your email id
thank you everyone for joining today's
session and uh we'll now meet for the
next session on may 27th the session on
may 27th is going to be a live session
that would be taken up by dr drakovinder
we will see you in our next session and
the participants will get the program
participants will get the invitation
link and also in case uh the email drops
in the spam box or the other promotions
box please uh drop it or drag and drop
it to the inbox main inbox and another
way to get the access to to the session
is definitely the program page once
you're a part of the program page you
will be able to look at the zoom
recordings as well for the zoom session
link as well for the session
so that was it for today's session thank
you everyone for joining it was nice to
have you all